in the modern world many countries have
lotteries and every week many millions
of people participate in the hope of
suddenly acquiring a substantial fortune
a striking thing is that it's often
quite disadvantaged and uneducated
people who are most enthusiastic about
lotteries we might smile at their folly
in getting statistics quite so wrong if
they had the wisdom and mathematical
intelligence to understand how slim
their chances really were they'd surely
never bother the chances of winning the
largest payout is one in 40 million
nearly the same probability has been one
of the Queen's children currently a one
in fifteen million chance we naturally
feel a bit sorry for people investing in
such slender hopes they're taking aim at
an impossibly small target but we're no
better we may not have a sense that
we're playing any kind of lottery and
yet we are the lottery of life we too
are clutching tickets of various kinds
and setting our sights on statistical
near miracles even while we think were
being utterly sober rational and
level-headed the crucial place where
this lottery like behaviour happens is
in relation to our hopes of happiness in
two areas in particular love and work if
we were forced to spell out a picture of
an ideally successful life it might go
something like this
early on we pick just the right area of
work to apply ourselves to we swerve
neatly into new fields at the ideal
moment and get public recognition money
and honor for our efforts work is fun
creative and utterly in line with our
talents there are similar satisfactions
to be had around love after a spate of
compelling and passionate relationships
we meet one very special beautiful kind
and devoted person who understands us
completely often without us needing to
communicate with words sex is
extraordinary and children and
domesticity never grind us down we enjoy
perfect health and retire with the
feeling of having accomplished what we
set out to do
and enjoy a dignified respected old age
admired by our descendants and
occasionally exercising a deft guiding
touch behind the scenes as an amine or
squeeze we die gently in our late 90s
for non painful illness in a tranquil
flower filled room having written a wise
and generous will such scenarios occur
about as often as a payout at the
lottery but to our surprise despite our
education and apparently realistic and
practical natures we may have strongly
invested in some modified version of
just this form of ideal life we don't
quite grasp just how rare and strange 90
years on earth are without major
disasters in love and work our brains
the 40 walnuts through which we assess
reality have a habit of faithfully
misunderstanding statistics we imagine
that some things are much more common
than they really are we might suppose
that half of new businesses are a great
success in fact it's less than 2% we
readily suppose that a lot of people
have flat stomachs there in Australia
for instance only 2% of adults have a
slender physique in the UK about half
the population feels worried about money
on any particular day half of marriages
collapse and 60% of the population feel
that no one really loves them but we
rarely keep these kinds of facts in mind
when we plot our own trajectories part
of the reason lies with what we read and
see without anything necessarily
sinister lying behind this the media
continually bring anomalies to our
notice and so we end up feeling we're
inhabited a very different kind of world
to the one we actually live in our
imagined society is likely to contain
many more murders rabid dogs man-eating
sharks and beautiful happy people than
the real world does a mental map of how
much contentment is possible defies all
the known facts if we could really see
what love and work were like for most
other people we'd be so much less sad
about our own situation and attainments
if we could fly across the world and
peer into everyone's lives and minds
like an all-seeing angel we perceive how
very frequent disappointment is how much
unfulfilled ambition is circulating how
much confusion and uncertainty is being
played out in private and how many tears
and intemperate arguments unfold with
every new day and then we'd realize just
how statistically speaking abnormal and
therefore cruel the goals we have set
ourselves really are it would be a
painful lesson in some ways we might be
shocked and saddened by what we saw
we'd be disappointed of course to
conclude that in all probability we
wouldn't achieve what we'd hope for but
in another way this would be a
comforting and deeply reassuring
experience we'd feel a little bit more
tenderness towards ourselves for not
having in effect won the lottery of life
without being overtly naive most of us
are holding out hopes equivalent to
thinking we might win euromillions or
the powerball jackpot we don't deserve
criticism we need to pity ourselves for
the formidable obstacles that sit in the
way of the kind of success that it's so
normal to want and yet so rare to have
you